翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん こんにちは
（観客）こんにちは
北海道情報大学
メディアデザイン専攻４年の
福田賢人と申します
私はこのような
文字やイラストなどに
動きが加わった —
モーショングラフィックスという
映像を作っています
この映像は
私が今まで作ってきた映像を
一つにまとめたものです
今日は 私が大学入学後
どのように映像を作ってきたのかを
お話したいと思っています
私は 幼い頃から
ものを作るのが好きでした
高校３年生の進路を決める時に
担任の先生が
北海道情報大学のパンフレットを
僕のところに持ってきてくれて
情報大学の
メディアデザイン専攻というところで
デザインを学べると知りました
私は絵が下手で デザインなんて
もちろんやったことがなかったのですが
もしかしたら私にも かっこいいデザインを
作ることができるかもしれない
そんな希望をもって
ここ北海道情報大学に入学しました
しかし 入学してすぐに
デザインの難しさを痛感します
これは 私が 大学１年生の頃に作った
イタリアンレストランのショップカードを
作るという課題だったんですが
見ての通り
思っていたようなかっこいいデザインを
作ることはできませんでした
そして周りには 私より上手な
デザインを作れる人がたくさんいました
私のデザインに対するモチベーションは
どんどん下がり
大学１年生の終わり頃には
もうデザインを諦めていました
大学２年生になり
たまたまネットサーフィンをしていた時に
ニコニコ動画で観た
初音ミクの映像に
私は心を奪われました
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
とてもかっこいいですよね
この 音と完全に同期した
映像の気持ちよさや
このデザインに私は惹かれました
それから 映像制作に興味を持ち
独学で始めてみようと思いました
それが 2012年の
6月1日のことです
私は その日の夜に
さっそく自宅で映像を作りました
その時の映像がこちらです
（音楽開始）
[（英語）映像 フクダケント]
[（英語）音楽 ナカミショウタロウ]
[（英語）一度のチャンス]
[（英語）終]
（音楽終了）
当時は CGのスキルが全くなかったので
家にあったカメラを使って
この映像を作りました
私はどんどん映像制作に
夢中になりました
大学２年生の頃に受講していた
プロジェクト・トライアルという講義で
私はファープという
男性化粧品会社を企画しました
その時に作った映像がこちらです
（音楽開始）
（ナレーター）目覚めよ 男たち！
色づくワックス！
そう 男は変われる
[男が華でもいいじゃない]
自分の髪質に合わせて
選べる４つのタイプ
ファープ 新登場！
（音楽終了）
この時は もう
とにかく映像を作るのが楽しくて
朝から晩まで
常に映像のことを考えて
作っているような生活でした
ただ スキルが全然なかったので
自分の作りたいような
かっこいい映像が作れず
常にモヤモヤしていました
大学３年生になり
私は 何か結果を出したいと
強く思うようになりました
自信が欲しかったんです
そして私は ギャッツビーの
CMを作るというコンテストを見つけ
この映像を応募しました
（音楽開始）
[スパイキーエッジ]
[ワイルドシェイク]
[マルチフォーム]
[ルーズシャッフル]
[ギャツビー]
[エアライズ]
[クールウェット（ひんやりしっとり）]
[グランジマット]
（音楽終了）
この映像は結局だめで
入賞できませんでした
当時の私は かなり自信があったので
入賞できなかった時に
とても落ち込みました
なぜこの映像は
入賞できなかったのでしょうか？
この映像コンテストでは
アイデアや企画の斬新さや
おもしろさを求めていたんですが
当時の私は CGの技術にばかりに
夢中になっていて
アイデアや企画のことは
まったく考えていませんでした
それがいけなかったんですね
そして私は気がつきました
技術ばかり勉強しててもだめなんだ
それからは もちろん技術も
勉強するんですが
アイデアや企画のことを
もっと考えるようになりました
それから少し経って
大学３年生の終わり頃に
Twitterで ある方から
ボーカロイドのミュージック・ビデオを
作って欲しいと頼まれました
私は作った映像を
YouTubeに公開していたので
それをたまたま観て
声をかけてくれたみたいです
そんなこともあるんですね
そして作ったのが
キャラメルタルトという映像です
（音楽開始）
♪ その目が私のことを見て ♪
♪ 触れてくれるなんて ♪
♪ 夢の中だけのことなの ♪
♪ 知ってたはずで ♪
♪ どうしてこんなに涙の粒が ♪
♪ 落ちるんだろう ♪
♪ 好き未満で終わりたいのに ♪
♪ もうどうしよう ♪
[キャラメルタルト]
（音楽終了）
この映像を作って
ニコニコ動画に投稿したところ
約５万回も観てもらうことができました
歌詞が若い子の恋愛を
テーマにしたものだったので
最近の若い子は
スマートフォンやSNSを使って
恋愛しているんじゃないかと思い
このような映像を作りました
それが珍しかったみたいで
動画のコメントでも
「新しい」とか 「おもしろい」とか
言ってもらえたので
私はとってもうれしかったです
この時に 改めて感じたのが
技術力の高さではなくて
アイデアや企画の強さがあれば
おもしろいと思ってもらえるので
このように映像を
作っていこうと思いました
大学４年生になり
私はもう一人前になったつもりでした
しかし ある日
同じゼミの女の子に
こんなことを言われます
「福田の作る映像って
かっこいいんだけど
なんかどっかで観たことが
あるような感じだよね」
私はこの一言に
結構 グサッときました
それまでは他の方が作った作品の
かっこいいと思うところを真似したり
それに何か足したりして
映像を作っていたんですが
それが自分の映像に
表れていたんですね
このあたりから
今までにないような新しい映像を
作りたいと思うようになりました
そしてこんな映像を
作ってみました
（音楽開始）
これは今年の
北海道情報大学の
CMコンテストに
応募した映像です
QRコードを
映像やCMに使っているものは
今までになかったので
QRコードをデザインして
さらにアニメーションを
させてみました
また こんな映像も作りました
（音楽開始）
♪ 行けたらいいな 東京シティ ♪
♪ 行けたらいいなぁ ♪
♪ 行けたら 行けたら 行けたら ♪
（音楽終了）
3DCGの技術で
紙の質感に挑戦したこの映像は
北海道映像コンテスト2014の
学生部門で優秀賞をいただきました
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
Twitter で知り合った方と
こんな映像も作ってみました
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
お墓にプロジェクションマッピングしたんです
お墓に映像を投影するなんて
まあとても不謹慎ですよね
もちろん 発泡スチロールで
作った偽物です
このように いろいろ試行錯誤して
映像を作るんですが
なかなか 自分の
オリジナリティがでてきません
私は悩んだ結果
CGを使って映像を作ることが
多かったので
他の表現手法も試してみよう
そう思いました
その時に試しに作ってみた
手描きアニメーションがこちらです
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
どうでしょうか？
私は少しですが
手応えがありました
もしかしたら
手描きのアニメーションを使って
個性的な映像を作ることが
できるかもしれない
そう思い 私は大学４年間の
集大成となる卒業制作で
手描きアニメーションを
作ることに決め
現在 製作中です
最後になりましたが
先ほど流れたTEDxHIUの
オープニングムービーも
私が作りました
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
私が 映像制作に興味を持ったのは
たまたま ニコニコ動画で観た
初音ミクの映像でした
それから たくさん映像を作って
顔も知らないネット上の
クリエーターとコラボレーションしたり
映像のコンテストで
賞をいただいたり
来年の4月からは
東京の映像制作会社で
働けることにもなりました
インターネットには
まだまだいろいろな
可能性があると思うので
私はこれからも
もっと勉強していきます
そして インターネットには
たくさんのコンテンツがありますが
オリジナリティが
大切だと思うので
自分のオリジナリティについても
深く追求していきたいと考えています
これが私の考えです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）